Selamlar. Ne haber? Nasılsın? İyi misin?
Umarım iyisindir. Keyifler de
yerindedir. Geldik 6. adıma. Kolay bir
kısım. Rahatça halledeceğiz. Neyden
bahsedeceğiz? Isı iletimi yollarından
bahsedecek. Hiçbir esprisi yok. Ben sana
söyleyeyim. Zaten günlük hayatta da
bayağı ilişkili olduğu için çok
rahatlıkla anlayacağım bir alan. Şu üç
tane ısı iletim yolunu inceleyeceğiz
desenle. Konveksiyonu, iletime bir de
ışayı inceleyeceğiz. Ben zaten günlük
hayat örneklerini vereceğim. Karşına
bununla ilgili bir tane soru sorulur.
Kesinlikle sözel bir soru sorulacaktır
ama çat diye hemen yapacaksın. Hiç merak
etme. O zaman ne diyelim? Sen hazırsın.
Ben hazırım. Ekim tutar bizi. Haydi gel
başlayalım. Şimdi sol sütuna bakalım
bize ne diyormuş. Bir anlamaya
çalışalım. Isı iletim yolları. Şimdi ısı
sıcaklığı yüksek olan maddeden düşük
olana doğru geçiyordu. Bunu zaten
konunun en başından beri herhalde bir 50
defa söyledik. Bu geçiş ancak üç farklı
yolla gerçekleşebiliyor.
Şimdi birincisi iletim. İletim dediğim
an aklına gelecek olan şey katı gelmesi
lazım. Katılarda olan bir şeydir iletim.
İletim nerede olur? Bir şeyi
iletiyorsun. Katı da iletirsin değil mi?
Evet. Izı taneciklerinin birbiriyle
temas sayesinde aktarılır. Bu yol
genellikle katı maddelerde etkilidir.
Şimdi bak şunu baştan sana söyleyeyim.
Normalde ısının iletim yollarını biz 3
ayırıyoruz ama sadece biri yok. Etkin
olan biri var. Yani iletim mesela %95
baskındır. %5 de atıyorum konveksiyon
vardır. Sana hep en etkili olanı
soracaklar. O yüzden şöyle düşünme. İşte
hiç ışıma yok mu? Olacak. Hiç
konveksiyon yok mu? Bir tık olacak. Ama
biz neyi arayacağız? Hep en baskın
olanı. Zaten bunu da sana mesela bazı
anahtar cümlelerle hissettirecek. Sana
burada çözüm yolunda bir pratiklik
sağlayacak. Mesela iletim neredeymiş?
Katı maddelerde. E mesela günlük
hayattaki örneği yine? Bir tane soğuk
bir kaşığı aldın. Sıcak çay bardağına
koydun. Çay içeceksin, karıştıracaksın.
Çay nedir? Sıcaktır. Kaşık nedir?
Soğuktur. Koyarsın. Bir ik dakika
beklediğinde kaşığın ne olduğunu
hissediyorsun. Böyle ucundan tuttuğunda
hani uç kısmı ıslanmamasına rağmen yani
çayla temas etmemesine rağmen direkt
olarak ne oluyor? Uç kısmı da ısınıyor.
İşte ısı oraya nasıl geldi? İriim
sayesinde geldi. Soğuk bir kaşığı sen
sıcak çay bardağına koyduğunda bir süre
sonra kaşığın diğer ucu da ne oluyor?
aslında ısınıyor. Çünkü ısı kaşığın
metal gövdesi boyunca ne oluyor aslında?
İletiliyor. İşte bunun aslında örneği
nerede? Burada sıcak bir çayın var,
soğuk bir kaşığın var. Ne oluyor? Bak bu
taneciklerle beraber tanecikler
aracılığıyla burada ne oluyor? Bir
iletim oluyor. İşte bu kaşığın
ısınmasında, bu kaşığın sıcaklığının
artmasında etkili olan ısı iletim yolu
ne olacaktır benim için? İletim
olacaktır. Bunlar işte sana hep ne
olacak aslında? İpucu olacak. Başka bir
örneği var mı? Tabii ki de var. Mesela
kışın evdesin, ayağında çorap yok. Taşa
basıyorsun, koridorda geziniyorsun. Sen
kışın çıplak ayakla taşemine basınca bir
anda ne yapıyorsun? Üşümeye başlıyorsun.
Ayakların üşüyor. Neden? Çünkü kış
aylarında burası nedir aslında senin
için? Soğuktur. Senin bacağınsa nedir?
Sıcaktır. Vücut sıcaklığımız nedir? 38,5
derecedir. Eğer evinizde yerden ısıtma
yoksa muhtemelen buradaki taş zemin ne
olacaktır? soğuk olacaktır. Eee, sıcak
maddeden soğuk maddeye doğru bir ısı
iletimi olmuyor mu? Evet. Isı nereden
nereye aktarılıyor burada? Sıcak
maddeden. Yani ayağından taş zemine
doğru. Burada etkili olan ısı iletim
yolu ne peki? Etkili olan tabii ki de
katı olduğu için, katılar birbiriyle bir
nevi temas ettiği için, katıyla alakalı
konuştuğumuz için burada da nedir? İşte
iletimdir. Ha bunun tam tersi de mümkün.
Yani burası mesela bir yerden ısıtma
vardır. Zemin biraz bayağı sıcaktır.
Tamam mı? Ne olur? Bu sefer ayağının
ısındığını hissedersin. Güzel. Ee senin
ayağına bu ısı neyle aktarılıyor? İşte
iletim yoluyla aktarıldığını
söyleyebilirsin. Ne diyor burada? Kışın
çıplak ayakla taş zemine basınca bir
anda üşümeye başlarsın. Çünkü taş
vücudundan hızlıca ne yapacaktır? Bir
ısı çekecektir.
Diğer bir arkadaş kim? Konveksiyon.
Diğer adı aslında taşınımdır. Şimdi
konveksiyon dediğimiz şey neymiş? Sıvı
veya gaz moleküllerinin bak anahtar
cümle geldiği yer değiştirmesiyle ne
yapıyormuş? Taşınıyormuş. Bu yolla ısı
taşıma sadece sıvı ve gazlarda olur.
Katılarda olan neydi? İletimdi. Bak sıvı
ve gazlarda olan ne olacak peki?
Konveksiyon olacak. Isı alan gazın
tanecikleri arasındaki boşluklar
artıyor. Neden? Sıcaklığı artıyor, hacmi
artıyor diyebilirsin. Tanecikler
birbirinden uzaklaşıyor diyebilirsin. Bu
da öz kütleyi azaltır. Öz kütlesi azalan
sıcak hava yükselirken soğuk hava ve
yoğun hava aşağı iner. Bu döngüyle de
sıcak ve soğuk hava ne yapıyor? Yer
değiştiriyor. Nerede görüyorsun bunu?
Kalorifer sistemlerinde. Kalorifer
sistemleri neden duvarda yerde oluyor?
Yerdeki havayı ısıtıyor. O ısınan hava
yükseliyor. Soğuk hava dibe çöküyor,
aşağı çöküyor. Güzel. O da ısınıyor,
yukarı çıkıyor. Soğuyor, aşağı iniyor,
ısınıyor. Bak sürekli ne var? Bir devir
daim var. O yüzden odalardaki kalorifer
sistemleri işte soba sistemleri, ısıtma
sistemleri gibi arkadaşlar nedir aslında
burada ısınma iletim yolu? Konveksiyon
oluyor. Mesela sen bir çorba yapıyorsun.
Ne yapıyorsun? Çorbayı karıştırıyorsun,
değil mi? Çorba karıştırırken ne
yapıyorsun? Aslında burada bir
karıştırma işlemi yapıyorsun. Tanecikler
ne yapıyorsun? Bir yer değiştiriyorsun.
Devir daim yapıyorsun. İşte buradaki
devir daim olayı olduğu için burada
ısınmasında yani şu çorbanın kendi
içerisine ısınmasında bir nevi etkili
olan şey nedir? Konveksiyondur. Şuna
kabulü. Ocak vardır burada mesela. Ocak
ne yapıyor burada? Tencereyi de
ısıtıyor. Değil mi? Mesela bu tencerenin
kupları da ısınıyor. Direkt tuttuğunda
ne olacaktır? Elin yanacaktır. Allah
korusun. Ee mesela o kupların
ısınmasında etkili olan ne? Hemen aklına
ne geliyor? Katı geliyor. Ha katı olduğu
için orada etkili olan ne olacaktır?
İletim olacaktır. Ama çorbayı aldın
böyle kaba aldın ocaktan şöyle tezgahın
üzerine koydun. Karıştırıyorsun mesela
bir devir daim oluyor. Ne oluyor o devir
daim sayesinde? Her yerde bu maddelerin
yerini değiştiriyorsun. Taneciklerin
yeri değişiyor. Bir nevi orada ısıyı ne
yapıyorsun? bir dağıtıyorsun gibi
düşünebilirsin. E buradaki devir daimden
dolayı bu çorbanın ısınmasında bir nevi
etkili olan şey nedir? Konveksiyondur.
Mesela çorbanın üst yüzeyi biraz nedir?
Soğuktur mesela. Çünkü havayla temas
halinde alt taraflar sıcaktır. Sen
karıştırıyorsun, karıştırıyorsun.
Alttaki sıcak çorba taneciklerini üst
tarafa getiriyorsun. Bak ne yaptın?
Devir daimi yaptın. İşte bu ne olacaktır
senin için? Konveksiyon olacaktır. Bak
bu döngüyle sıcak ve soğuk hava ne
yapıyor aslında? yer değiştiriyor. Bir
yer değiştirme olayı varsa, bir devir
daim varsa aklına gelecek arkadaş ne
olacaktır? Konveksiyon olacaktır
diyebilirsin.
Üçüncü arkadaş kim? Işıma. Biz buna
radyasyon da diyoruz aslında. Isı
tanecik teması olmadan sadece enerji
şeklinde eğilir. He kilit cümle geldi.
Enerji şeklinde eğiliyor. Tüm maddeler
aslında ışıma yapar. Bu ne demek hocam?
Şimdi her madde sıcaklığından dolayı bir
ışıma yapıyor. Aslında sen de bir ışıma
yapıyorsun. Belki hatırlıyor musun?
Bilmiyorum ama pandemi vardı. Pandemi
zamanı havalimanlarında, otagarlarda
insanlar şöyle bir dedektörle
bakıyorlardı. İşte o dedektör neyi
ölçüyor aslında biliyor musun? O senden
olan ışımayı ölçüyor. Belli bir değerin
üstündeyse he sende hastalık var. Niye?
Çünkü vücut sıcaklığın çok yüksek. He
niye? Senin ateşin var diyorlar. İşte
tüm maddeler aslında ne yapar? Bir ışıma
yapar. Ancak boşlukta yayılabilen tek
ısı aktarım yoludur. Hangi cümleyi
hatırlayacaksın? Boşluk diye. Bak şu
olmasın yalnız. İlla boşluk olması şart
değil. Hava ortamında da ışımın
örnekleri var. Birazdan bahsedeceğim.
Ancak bizim mesela güneşin dünyayı
ısıtmasından bahsediyoruz. Ne yapıyor?
Güneş dünyamızı ısıtıyor, değil mi?
Yazın çok sıcak havalar görüyoruz. E
dünya nasıl ısınıyor? Arada bir hava
falan var mı? Yok. Bir konveksiyondan
bahsedemezsin. E arada katı bir madde
yok. Bir iletimden de bahsetmesin. Ne
var burada? Boşluk var. Ne oluyor?
Enerji şeklinde geliyor bize. Enerji
şeklinde geldiği için güneşin dünyayı
ısıtması nedir? Aslında bir ışıma
örneğidir. Mesela bu soba ne yapıyor?
Odayı ısıtıyor. Evet. Konveksiyon var
mı? Tabii ki de var. Buna hiçbir
itirazım yok. Ama sen sobanın
yanındayken direkt soba taneciklerinden
soba tanecikleri diyorum. Isı ne oluyor?
Sana gelebiliyor. Tamam bir devir daim
de var ama sana da bu şekilde geliyor.
Burada da az miktarda aslında ne var?
Bir ışıma var diyebilirsin. Mesela
evinde şöyle bir deney yapabilirsin.
Ocağı açın. Tamam mı? Ocağı açtığınızda
ocağın üzerinde şöyle elinizi
tuttuğunuzda 34 saniye falan en fazla
elinizi tutarsınız. Hatta 4 saniye bile
fazla hemen elini çekeceksin. Ne oldu?
Ocağın o çevresindeki hava tancıkları
ısındı. Bir anda yükseldi. Soğuk hava ne
oldu? Aşağı indi. Burada etkili olan ne?
Konveksiyon. Ama ocağı elinde böyle
değil de yandan böyle tutarsan bir 30-40
saniye herhalde tutabilirsin. Böyle
yaptığında aslında ne oluyor? Burada
elin ısınıyor ama konveksiyon kadar
güçlü değil. Burada olan ne oluyor
aslında? ışı mı oluyor? Konveksiyonda ne
oluyordu? Çünkü ısınan hava
yükseliyordu. Soğuk hava ne oluyor?
Düşüyordu. Yandan tuttuğunda ne oluyor?
Aslında bir nevi temas yok. Sonuçta bir
katım olayı yok. Bir konveksiyon yok.
Hani bir nevi devir daimi yok. Yandan
tuttuğun için ne olacaktır? 30-40 saniye
elini tutabilirsin. Zayıf da olsa orada
ne var? Aslında bir ışıma var
diyebilirsiniz. Sobanın karşısında
durduğunda vücudunun ısındığını
hissedersin. Bu da aslında ışıma ile
olan bir ısı aktarım yolu oluyor. Tamam.
Olay aslında bu. Günlük hayat
örneklerini ne yapabilirsin? Aslında
çoğaltabilirsin. Mesela klimaların odayı
soğutması bir devir daimdir. Neden
yukarıya koyuyoruz? Soğuk hava üflüyor.
Soğuk hava direktman ne yapar? Özkütlesi
yoğun olduğu için yere doğru gider. Eee
ısınan havayı da soğutuyorsun. Ne
yapıyorsun? Aslında ısınan hava sonuçta
yukarıda aşağı düşüyor. Bir ne var
aslında? Devir daim var. Kalorifer
sistemleri, ısıtma soğutma sistemleri.
Niye biz kaloriferi tavana yapmıyoruz da
yere yapıyoruz? E sonuçta bizim amacımız
ne? O soğuk havayı ısıtıp yukarı
çıkartmak. Değil mi? E yukarıdaki havayı
yukarı çıkartamayacağımıza göre
mantıksız olacaktır. Devir daim olmazdı.
O zaman ne var? Yerden ısıtma var.
Yüksekten ısıtma ya da tavandan ısıtma
diye bir şey ben duymadım. Aslında sebep
bu. Şimdi ısığa aktarım yolları olan
iletim, konveksiyon ve ışıma çoğu
durumda bir arada işte dediğim gibi
bulunabilir. Ancak biz burada neyi
konuşacağız? Her zaman en etkili olan
arkadaşı konuşacağız. Ancak her ortamda
bir tanesi baskın olacaktır. Bu da
ortamın yapısına ve maddenin haline ne
olacaktır? bağlı olacaktır. Yayılma yolu
iletim. Ne olacak? Ortam katılar olacak.
Mesela metal kaşığın ısınması. Bunu
örnek olarak verebilirsin. Buradaki
tencerenin kuplarının ısınması.
Tencerenin ısınması ocak üzerine
duruyor. Ne diyebilirsin? İtim
diyebilirsin. Konveksiyon kimde
görünüyor? Sıvı ve gazlarda. Ne var? Bir
devir daim var. Sobanın odayı ısıtması.
Kaloriferle odanın ısınması. Hepsi neye
örnektir aslında? Konveksiyona örnektir.
Işıma her ortamda olur. İlla boşlukta
olacak diye şart yok. Her ortamda olur
ama boşlukta oluyorsa direkt ışıma
diyebilirsin. Ancak her ortamda var.
Güneşin dünyaya ısıtması direkt
ışımadır. Hava yok ki konveksiyon olsun.
Arada katı madde yok ki iletimi olsun.
Ne oluyor mesela? Güneş ışınlarının
dünyayı ısıtması olarak bir günlük hayat
örneği verebilirsin. İşte şu üç arkadaşı
sana ne yapabilir? Sorabilir. Metal
kaşığın ısınmasında etkili olan, en
etkili olan ısı aktarım yolu nedir diye
sana sorular. Ne yapacaksın? İletim
patlatacaksın. Güneşin dünyayı ısıtması.
Neyi patlatacaksın? En etkili olan
ışımayı patlatacaksın. Kalorifer
sistemlerinin odayı ısıtmasında neyi
patlatacaksın? Konveksiyonu
patlatacaksın diyebilirsin. Gel şimdi ne
yapalım? Şuradaki örnek iki tane soruya
bir göz atalım. Burçin içerisinde sıcak
çay bulunan bir bardağı sıcaklığı daha
küçük olan bir metal kaşığı bırakıyor.
Bir buna göre yeterince beklendiğinde
yargılanan hangileri doğrudur demiş. Bir
kapı aldık. İçerisine ne koyduk? Sıcak
çayımızı koyduk. Oh mis gibi. İçerisine
bir tane de ne koyduk? Soğuk bir kaşık
koyduk. Güzel. E kaşık ne olacak? Isı
alacak mı? Alacak. Çay ısı verecek mi?
Verecek. Bu arkadaş ısınacak mı kaşık?
Evet. Hangi aktarım yoluyla mesela şu uç
kısımlarda ısınacak? İletimle. Neden?
Katı madde olduğu için. Sıcak çaydan
metal kaşığa ısı en etkili olarak iletim
yoluyla aktarılır diyor. Evet bu
doğrudur. Metal kaşığın iç enerjisi
artar diyor. Metal kaşık burada ısı aldı
mı? Aldı. Enerji aldı mı? Aldı. O zaman
iç enerjisi ne olacaktır? artacaktır.
Çayın sıcaklığı ne olur? Azalır. E niye
ısı veriyor? Sonuçta Isaklığı
ne olacaktır? Düşecektir. Oradaki bizim
çay kaşığımızın sıcaklığı ne olacaktır?
Artacaktır diyebilirsin. Çayın sıcaklığı
ne oldu? Azaldı. Bu yargı da doğru oldu.
Doğru cevabımız E şıkkı olmuş oldu.
Isının iletimi sırasında farklı enerji
aktarım yolları vardır. Yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur diyor. Sobanın
bulunduğu odayı ısıtmasında etkili olan
ısı aktarım yolu nedir? Konveksiyondur.
Ne var çünkü? Devir daim var. Isınan
hava yükselir. Soğuyan hava aşağı doğru
düşer. Sürekli ne var aslında? Bir devir
daim var. Bunu söyleyebilirsin. En
etkili nedir? Konveksiyondur. Yanında
dururken böyle yanında soba duruyor.
Artık soba kullanıyor musunuz bilmiyorum
ama ne oluyor? Seni güzel güzel yandan
da ısıtıyor. Aslında orada etkili olan
şey ne oluyor senin için? Birazcık ışım
oluyor. Yan taraftasın ama böyle elini
sobanın üzerine şöyle tutarsan ne
oluyor? Isınan hava yükseliyor. Burada
etkili olan şey nedir? konveksiyondur.
Mikrodalga fırında yemeğin ısınmasında
etkili olan ısı aktarım yolu ışıma
yoluyla iletimdir. Şimdi mikrodalga
dediğimiz arkadaş evinizde vardır belki
yemeği koyarsın sonra bir süre sonra 1
ik dakika sonra ısınır. Şimdi burada
herhangi bir şekilde aslında ne yok bir
konveksiyon yok. Ne kullanılıyor aslında
burada? Mikrodalgalar kullanılıyor.
Enerji kullanıyor. Burada etkili olan
nedir aslında? Işıadır. Hani bir
konveksiyon değildir. Bir devir daimi
yapmıyoruz. Mikro dalgalar kullanılır.
Mikro dalgalar kullanıldığı için bir
nevi enerji aktarıldığı için buradaki en
etkili olan şey ne olacaktır? Işma
olacaktır. İçeride hava var mı? Var. Bak
ışıma sadece işte ne olmuyor? Sadece
boşlukta olmuyor. O yüzden ikinci
yargımız da ne olacaktır? Doğru
olacaktır. Yemek içerisindeki demir
kaşığının ısınmasında etkili olan ısı
aktarım yolu nedir peki? İletimdir.
Neden? Katı maddeden bahsediyorsun.
Örneklerini zaten vermiştik. İşte çay
kaşığı örneği vermiştik. Yemek kaşığı
örneği vermiştik vesaire. Bunların
ısınmasında en etkili olan arkadaş
iletim olacaktır. 3ün yargı da doğru. O
yüzden doğru cevabımız E şıkkı oldu. 1E
2e. Bir sıkıntı yok. Bak ne yaptık. Bu
adımı da tertemiz 15 dakikada zaten
halletmiş olduk. Ben sana söyleyeyim.
Gayet basit, gayet kolay, hiçbir sıkıntı
yaşamayacağın bir kısım. Sonraki adımda
ne yapacağız? Birazcık ısı alışverişi
ile ilgili hesaplamalar yapacağız. Bu
hesaplamalar biraz sorulabiliyor.
Birazcık ek adım tadında yapacağız.
Zorlayıcı olmayacak ama kafan dinç
gelmesi. Dinç olarak gelmen benim için
önemli. O zaman ne diyelim? 7. adımda
görüşmek üzere diyelim. Kendine çok iyi
bak. Hoşça kal. Yeah.